hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast accelerating tuberculosis
elimination with genomics presented by
dr. Jennifer Guardi an associate
professor in Canada Research Chair in
Public Health genomics at the University
of British Columbia and a senior
scientist at the BC Centre for Disease
Control
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab routes is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation just click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and dust offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me now in welcoming our presenter
dr. Guardi I will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome dr.
Gauri thank you dr. Valdes and it's a
pleasure to be here speaking to you all
today about some of the work that we're
doing up in British Columbia Canada on
using whole genome sequencing as a tool
to accelerate our progress towards
tuberculosis elimination now for those
of you who might not be familiar with TB
I thought I'd start with a bit of a
recap of TB is something that people
often say well why are you still working
on that I thought that was a disease of
the past but in fact the opposite is
true
TB is actually the number one infectious
disease killer worldwide
it's surpassed HIV a long time ago and
in terms of a single infectious disease
it is the number one killer despite the
fact that we have
medication to treat TV there's a number
of different antibiotics that are
effective at treating the organism when
we talk about tuberculosis infection and
disease we're talking about two
different things
latest TB infection which we often
abbreviate to L TBI is a type of TB
infection where the TB germ is in your
lung it's being walled up in a little
kind of a little ball called a granuloma
that your immune system is created and
kind of keeps under control and latent
TB infection isn't transmissible it
doesn't cause any symptoms you're not
actually sick with any TB disease in
fact about a quarter of the world's
population is actually estimated to have
latent TB infection only about one in
ten of those individuals though will
ever go on to develop active
tuberculosis disease active TB disease
is when the TB bacterium escapes from
that little ball the granuloma starts
replicating in your lung and actually
causing symptoms so transmission of TB
only occurs from active TB disease cases
people that are symptomatic and
infectious and transmission is through
the airborne route along with measles TB
is one of the truly airborne pathogens
where you could coughs um TB bacilli
into a room leave that room and then
somebody that comes in a short time
later might inhale those and receive the
TB bacterium there is a spectrum of
infectiousness in terms of how likely
people are to transmit TB to another TB
can really cause disease anywhere in the
body we do primarily think of it as a
lung disease but it can cause infection
pretty much anywhere so people that have
what we call extra pulmonary TB or not
in their lungs they tend not to be
infectious they don't transmit onwards
and even amongst people that do have the
pulmonary form of TB there still is
quite a range of how infectious they are
largely depending on how many TB bacilli
they're coughing out and if you pay any
attention to the TB
world at all you probably are aware of
the fact that antimicrobial resistance
is an emerging issue that we're dealing
with we often talk about drug-resistant
TB or multi drug-resistant TB where
you've got resistance to multiple TB
antibiotics as well as increasing rates
of what we call XDR or extremely
drug-resistant TB where you're resistant
to virtually everything that we could
treat your TB with so this is an
emerging issue in TB MDR TB is arising
de novo and people that have difficulty
completing the course of antibiotics
that they've been given for whatever
reason and we're also seeing
transmission of drug-resistant TB and an
interesting thing about antibiotic
resistance in tuberculosis which is
different from a lot of other microbes
is that that resistance is driven by
point mutations it's single nucleotide
changes in the TB genome that lead to
those resistant phenotypes TB is
unevenly distributed around the globe in
terms of TB incidence rates or the
burden of disease you can see the blue
or the country on this map the higher
the TB rate so in places like North
America our TB rates tend to be quite
low generally less than ten cases per
100,000 typically closer to something on
the order like three to five cases per
hundred thousand population but in
places like Southeast Asia sub-saharan
Africa rates are quite high in the
hundreds and hundreds of cases per
hundred thousand and because of the way
that doing a migration works and the way
the world is these days we often say
that TB anywhere is TB everywhere so
people that are migrating from higher
incidence countries can often bring that
latent TB infection remember a quarter
of the world's population might have LT
bi they can bring that infection with
them to other parts of the world where
eventually it might go on to wake up and
become active disease so in settings
where there's fairly good laboratory
infrastructure you've got TB labs
reference laboratories that are
responsible for all sorts of aspects of
the boring investigations of TB from
diagnosing the TB infection
is also a lot of other micro bacterial
species out there beyond Mycobacterium
tuberculosis that causes TB so a
mycobacteria ology lab is often trying
to different differentiate does this
person have Mycobacterium tuberculosis
or do they have one of the Indians
non-tuberculous mycobacteria that don't
cause TB disease Laboratories are also
responsible for phenotyping so they're
doing antibiotic sensitivity testing of
isolates that come in and they do
genotyping as well DNA fingerprinting to
determine whether a newly diagnosed
isolate is perhaps part of an outbreak
and related to cases that we've seen
before so currently some of the
molecular tools that are used there's
some very simple tools a lot of
diagnosis just happens via a culture but
we do do some molecular work as well
using PCR for diagnosis and then the
genotyping techniques that we use in
order to be in a fingerprint TB isolates
the classic genotyping technique is
something called miru vntr I often just
refer to it as miru for short and that
stands for micro bacterial interspersed
repetitive unit variable number tandem
repeat so it's a series of 20 for
repetitive locations around the
Mycobacterium tuberculosis genome that
we amplify up with PCR run on the gel
and we can estimate the repeat size and
that gives us a very simple way of
representing a DNA fingerprint so this
is what your classic TB lab might look
like and that's what I have access to at
the British Columbia Center for Disease
Control so this is where I work this is
it lovingly rendered and watercolor
painting and it's a really interesting
place to be a scientist because we are
the provincial health agency we do
handle everything related to
communicable disease laboratory work
surveillance epidemiology for the entire
province of BC so it's got very
extensive sample data I mean we've got
all of the TB culture from all of the
cases of TB diagnosed in BC but we also
have a lot of rich information about the
patients and the populations and the
communities that those isolates are
from so when we want to study TV from a
combined molecular and epidemiological
perspective we're really tremendously
lucky and that we've got access to this
wonderful array of data so in British
Columbia our tuberculosis rate is
generally around two five to six cases
per hundred thousand population and
that's a rate that it's slightly higher
than the Canadian average and that's
largely due to the fact that British
Columbia is a province that receives a
lot of immigrants from other countries
particularly countries around the
Pacific Rim and we know that in places
like China like Vietnam like the
Philippines there can be very high TB
rates so we do get a lot of people that
were born outside of Canada in the
hyerin's in its setting moving to
British Columbia at some point in their
time here are their TB progresses from
latent active disease and that I think
accounts for our slightly higher case
rates than some of the other provinces
out there in terms of what trends what
that translates to in actual numbers we
typically see around 250 cases of TB in
British Columbia each year and the vast
majority of those are in persons born
outside of Canada approximately 80
percent and one of the nice things about
TB in our backyard is that drug
resistance isn't really a big issue for
us ninety percent of the TB cases that
we diagnose those isolates are fully
sensitive to all the frontline
antibiotics there's only a very small
handful of cases that are resistant to a
single antibiotic and in even smaller
handful of cases that are resistant to
multiple antibiotics so we seem to be in
a good position that's not a lot of
cases everything seems fairly manageable
however we're not on track to meet the
TB elimination goals that were recently
set by the World Health Organization
so TB elimination is defined as having
only one case per million population and
pre elimination is defined as ten cases
per million population so
right now we would love to be able to
meet those goals in 20 years from now in
30 years from now but if we look at the
current trajectory of declining TB case
rates this time I've put those in per
million population instead of per
hundred thousand population we can see
if we do a little extrapolation we're
not on target to meet those goals so
obviously we need to be doing something
different a few years ago a graduate
student of mine and I wrote this article
for a European with spiritual read
journal they had talked about in an
earlier ERJ articles the framework the
w-h-o framework for TB elimination in
low incidence settings places like
British Columbia places like North
America had been laid out in this
journal article and we read it and
realized that something they didn't talk
about in the article but that we felt
was a particularly promising approach to
really changing the way we approach TB
elimination is genomics and specifically
how we can use genomics as a tool to
both accelerate our time to diagnosing
an individual with a TB infection and
getting them initiated on the
appropriate antibiotic therapy as well
as a tool for helping us to understand
the epidemiology of TB transmission in a
region and use that information to stop
onward TB transmission so this article
kind of forms the basis for a lot of the
work that we've been doing in British
Columbia recently on incorporating
genome sequencing into our routine
tuberculosis prevention and care
programs so in BC we set our own
elimination strategy it's being ratified
by the province and it includes a couple
of different things as I told you know
the bulk of TB NBC is in persons born
outside of Canada
so in this population what we really
need to do is improve our screening for
latent TB infection and get people that
have been identified as having LT bi on
to therapy as soon as possible so we can
clear that infection and they're never
at risk of progressing to active disease
so that's more of a programmatic issue
but we're a genome sequencing I think
can help with this particular approach
is when an individual does progress to
active TB disease can we rapidly
diagnose them as having drug-resistant
TB most of our drug-resistant TB in
virtually all of our multi
drug-resistant TB does happen in persons
born outside Canada they acquired their
drug resistant infection overseas so it
really would be beneficial for us to be
able to very quickly identify that these
people have drug-resistant TB and get
them on the right antibiotic therapy
right away so that they become non
infectious and they're not transmitting
onwards and you'll hear more about that
in a little bit the other group that
we're dealing with in British Columbia
are people born inside of Canada where
TB is transmitting from person to person
in the province and when we look at
what's happening there really that
transmission is happening in the most
vulnerable of our Canadian born
population oftentimes these are people
that are living on the streets or a
transiently house so in this population
if we're to reach TB elimination we
really need to understand where why and
how
TB is transmitting in these groups and
that's an area where genomics holds
tremendous promise so what we have found
over the last time I guess we've been
working in this area since about 2008
2009 so over the last decade as we've
been thinking about how to incorporate
whole genome sequencing into our
practice we've gotten to the point where
we've now sequenced over 2,000 TB
genomes that have been collected going
back 13 years now and we're looking at
how can we use that information to
improve our drug resistance prediction
and how can we use that information to
trap TB that's transmitting in BC and
around Canada so how did we end up with
all these genomes what's kind of the
history of TB genomics in British
Columbia the timeline looks a little bit
like this so as I said we've been
working this area for about a decade in
2008
we were funded to do a project called
the 40 TB genomes project and this was
the time when next-generation DNA
sequencing technology was just starting
to become available to the research
community and the notion of sequencing
40 complete genomes from a single
bacterial species representing a single
outbreak of infectious disease seemed a
little crazy at the time but there was a
challenge we are willing to take on so
we went ahead and started that project
in 2009 we got the sequence data we were
only able to get sequenced for 36 of the
for teaching ohms that we had originally
hoped to do but that was enough for us
to begin looking at how can we tell what
happened in a TB outbreak from genome
sequence alone and you'll hear more
about how we do that in a bit but that
led to a paper in the New England
Journal of Medicine that was published
in 2011 where we really saw for the
first time demonstrated that genome
sequencing is a very useful tool for
epidemiology for reconstructing
outbreaks and that you could quite
feasibly figure out who transmitted to
whom it was really the first paper of
its kind in that bacterial genomic space
and at the same time that paper was
being published we also embarked on a
second outbreak investigation the one
that we had started in 2008 was looking
at an extremely large outbreak of TB in
one particular region of BC and in 2011
we started working on a second outbreak
which eventually came to be the biggest
outbreaks of TB in the province in
recent years and we looked at that with
genomics as well as part of the
real-time response to that outbreak
based on our work looking at a couple of
these TB outbreaks we managed to
convince our financial overlords to give
us money to go in sequence all of the TB
in BC so we launched a study that we
call the molecular and genomic
epidemiology of TB and BC and so what we
did with that was go back and
retrospectively genotype every single
case of TB we'd seen going back to 2005
so we genotyped it with mirrors
ntr DNA fingerprinting and what was cool
about that is as we were analyzing those
results in the early days of the project
they were so promising that in 2014 the
TV lab decided just to implement routine
mirrors entr genotyping for all isolates
that were coming in so by the finally
reach 2016 we were at the point where we
had genotyped about 2300 isolates every
culture positive case of TB in British
Columbia diagnosed between 2005 and 2014
so complete decade's worth of cases and
we whole genome sequenced 1400 of those
we were really interested in studying
disease transmission and resistance so
we sequenced preferentially two types of
isolates we sequence those isolates that
shared a DNA fingerprint with at least
one other isolate in the study cohort
and that would suggest that potentially
these could be recently transmitted
isolates and we also sequenced all of
those isolates that we had in the
laboratory measured a drug resistance
phenotype for so where we're at these
days is we switched from selective
sequencing that we did in that
retrospective study where we just
sequenced the transmitted isolates just
sequence the resistance isolates since
2015 we've been sequencing all of the
isolates if it is culture positive it
goes on the sequencer and so we've
completed a lot of the analysis for the
2005 to 2014 data which is what I'll
show throughout the rest of the
presentation
and we've got a lot of really
interesting data coming down the
pipeline that we're currently analyzing
from 2015 16 17 and now 20 18 so the
first story I'll tell that we were able
to derive from this incredibly useful
set of these thousands of TB genomes is
the story around how can we accelerate
people's diagnosis of TB and in
particular how can we accelerate getting
them on the right antibiotics therapy so
let's do a little imagination the
exercise here imagine that you are a
doctor expecting that your doctor who
also happens to be a cat
yes but imagine you're a doctor and you
have a patient that you suspect of
having TB the time line for that you
would take a sputum sample from your
patient you have them cost into a cup
and that student would arrive at our
provincial reference laboratory ideally
the day it's received or the day after
it would be Graham stand it would go on
to microscopy and we would look to see
whether we see any TB bacillus on that
microscope slide and we might get an
answer that says no or we might get an
answer that says yes so if we did get
the answer that said yes we would do a
very quick PCR analysis with two primer
sets one that's designed to look for
Mycobacterium tuberculosis and one
that's designed to look for
Mycobacterium avium complex this is a
non tuberculous micro bacteria but those
two mycobacteria represents vast
majority of samples that come into the
lab so if you were lucky and there was
this Oh is visible under microscopy and
there was a positive PCR result you
might get a preliminary diagnosis
reported back to you within the space of
maybe one to four days but if you don't
get a preliminary diagnosis and even if
you do get a preliminary diagnosis we
still do put that sample into culture so
negative results and all samples really
go into culture and then we wait and
then we wait and we wait some more and
at some point typically the fastest this
might happen would be let's say gosh
about maybe seven to ten days after a
specimen is inoculated into culture we
might get a result saying that something
is culture positives but Mycobacterium
tuberculosis is a very very slow grower
and it might be as long as four five
maybe even six weeks before we get a
culture positive diagnosis back and we
can say yes your patient has TB so at
that point we've given you a diagnosis
you might have been waiting many weeks
for that and then we reenact you late
that sample into culture this time in
the presence of antibiotics and we wait
we
wait and we wait and eventually we get
the results of our drug sensitivity test
so we've tested frontline antibiotics
and you should be able to then say what
do you have in terms of a sensitive or a
resistant organism so at that point is
there is any drug resistance observed -
we then inoculate it into culture again
and we wait and we wait and hopefully we
get the results for any second line and
about it so if you're resistant to one
of the first-line antibiotics we want to
test your example to make sure it's not
resistant to any second line one you
have MDR TB so as you can imagine it's a
pretty long process getting somebody to
the point where we've got their drug
sensitivity results and their second
line drug sensitivity results
so that's clearly a long and drawn-out
process if you want to get an answer of
what does this patient have and what
antibiotics I should be treating them
with your often weighing many many weeks
sometimes even months as a clinician to
get your answer so together with an
international consortium led by Oxford
University a couple years ago we were
interested in asking the question could
a single whole genome sequencing
analysis replace all of those other
analyses and more importantly get you a
result an accurate result faster and the
long story made short the answer is yes
we publish this in Lancet respiratory
medicine in 2016 and what you've seen is
based on these pilot data public health
England the national public health
agency in the UK has now switched to
routine whole genome sequencing for
tuberculosis and you're also seeing that
happening in state and national labs
here in North America including of the
New York State Department of Public
Health so the premise behind whole
genome sequencing is a tool for TB
Diagnostics it's very simple what we
loop what we do is wait for a culture
positive isolate to be positive for one
day so we still need that culture step
we inoculate a specimen into culture and
wait for it to ding positives once it's
been positive for a day there should be
enough sequence abaq Tyrael material in
there in order to actually get genomic
data out so what we do is batch a few
typically 12 to 15 bacterial isolates TB
isolates that we've got off culture and
we sequence them often on the Illumina
buy seek once the sequencing is done the
raw sequence data is uploaded to a
central server where it's analyzed and a
report is returned to the clinician to
the laboratory that shows the results of
that particular analysis so what we've
seen with that one of the most
interesting things is looking at
resistant prediction so as I mentioned
off the top
when we look at the TB genome resistance
phenotypes are encoded by single
nucleotide changes point mutations so
the idea of resistance prediction in
silico basically says if we have a
catalog of known resistance mutations
can we look for those in the genome that
we've sequenced and from that if the
mutation is present
can we reliably predict a resistance
phenotype so together with that Oxford
consortium and a group around the world
we have a paper coming out very soon
looking at 10,000 TB genomes 1,400 of
which come from British Columbia and
saying can you reliably predict
resistance to common TB drugs like
isoniazid like rifampin and it turns out
that you can with actually surprisingly
good sensitivity and specificity so this
is really promising so as I said at the
top typically we might be waiting weeks
for drug sensitivity results to come in
on average in BC we're waiting just
about six weeks in total to get our GST
results but with whole genome sequencing
we can get those within a day or two of
a sample showing up of culture positives
so we can couple resistance prediction
in getting people on the right therapy
to diagnosis this is huge for
accelerating the time to getting people
on right the right therapy one other
thing that we've been working on as a
result of this collaboration with Oxford
and with public health England is how do
we avoid when we present to the results
of this genome sequencing based
diagnosis and phenotyping how do we
avoid overloading people who might not
have seen microbial genomic data before
how do we make the results clear to them
and not overload them with too much
complex genomic information because
there's a lot of computational biology
and a lot of genomics that goes into
putting together a resistance report on
putting together a diagnostic report how
do we make that information clear to
people
that pilot project there was a very
simple report that was designed the
report that we were using back in 2014
when we were engaged in this pilot
project but as the years went on and as
the bioinformatics capability of
analyzing TB genomes and deducing
interesting things from them gradually
increased we found that the
bioinformaticians who are generating
these reports started to put more and
more information on and that information
wasn't necessarily being communicated in
the clearest manner so the current
version the report that comes out
automatically at the end of this
sequencing an analysis pipeline looks
something like this and to somebody like
me who's been trained in computational
biology and microbial genomics I can
make sense of most of this fairly easily
but you can imagine a clinician a TB doc
who spent their entire life treating
patients and has never seen genome
sequencing before this could be rather
confusing to them so some of the work
that we've been doing really aimed at
making TB genomic data more actionable
more useful to a broader audience has
been around communicating these results
so this is some work that was done by a
graduate student and a medical resident
that we're working with me on a Kristen
and Jeff McKee and they did something
borrowed from the field of information
visualization within computer science
and it's the notion of a design study if
you want to create something that's
going to communicate information in this
case genomic laboratory test results to
end-users the way to do that effectively
is to figure out what those end users
need what are they doing with the data
and how can you visually present the
data in a way that's going to make their
life easier
so we did this design study process I'm
not going to go into this in great
detail there's an open-access paper that
you can read all about this but we did
find some interesting things we found
that when you're presenting laboratory
test results whether they're genomic or
not to people there's a lot of
constraints that are applied on that
process clinicians don't often have a
lot of time to review the report
they're often dealing with multiple
different documents that are coming in
at different times so they'll get a
diagnosis one day and then they have to
wait you know weeks to get the drug
sensitivity results and the report
formats that are used can be quite
different some public health agencies
are able to report results through
electronic health records others still
rely on faxing information back and
forth and depending who you are and your
role in TB prevention and care you might
want to do very different things with
the results of a TB genomic analysis if
you're a clinician you're probably just
interested in what does this patient
have and how am I going to treat them
but if you're somebody working in public
health you're probably more interested
in is this isolate that I've just
diagnosed part of a larger outbreak do I
have something troubling on my hands so
we got together and surveyed a bunch of
users we did a little process that's
referred to in information visualization
as the design sprint where you get a
group of people around a table designing
some different visual report prototypes
so we sketch those up manually then we
turn those into electronic versions we
developed for different prototype
reports and then we did a type of
experiment where we asked our end users
to evaluate individual components of the
report we were looking at small little
visual elements and giving them a choice
between two things saying hey when we
present results in this way versus this
way which one do you like better so for
example one of the questions we asked is
one more reporting out the wording that
we use to describe TB antibiotics
there's a couple different ways we could
do it we could use the drugs full name
every drug has a three-letter code and
TB they also have a one letter
abbreviation so we asked people those
clinicians and non clinicians working in
TB prevention which option do you prefer
and so we did this for all of the
different design elements in the report
whether it was you know drug names or
the type of table that we use and how
resistant isolates are highlighted
within the table is their highlighting
are they bolded are they shaded as
they're a little icon we went through
did this
every type of visual element that was
present on the report here's another
example where we looked at how do we
organize susceptibility and resistance
results and we ended up assessing a
whole bunch of different factors and
based on people's preferences for
particular design elements we were able
to arrive at a very simple final report
that meets the needs of our users that
takes complicated genomic information
you know hey we use genome sequencing to
diagnose this is a TB isolate and to put
it dis resistance phenotype and to
assign it to a cluster potential
outbreak and communicate it in a way
that makes sense and if you're
interested in following up that report
anymore the URL to that report is
available down at the bottom so that
kind of summarizes some of the work that
we've been doing on the resistence
prediction side of things and I wanted
to spend the last bit of time talking
about that other piece so part of
accelerating progress towards TB
elimination is diagnosing TB quickly
getting people in the right therapy
quickly but part of it is also
understanding outbreaks much better than
we do now and this is Dustin Hoffman's
1995 film outbreak it's a terrible movie
but it's one that I phone when I was a
teenager and said huh that's what I want
to do for the rest of my life so let's
look at how we investigate TB outbreaks
so right now our tuberculosis lab is
responsible for diagnosing cases of TB
within British Columbia so over the
course of a month you might get a whole
bunch of cases diagnosed and I
represented those by colored dots then
with DNA fingerprinting that mirror vntr
genotyping technique that I mentioned
earlier we fingerprint those isolates to
try to figure out are any of them
related to each other are they
genetically similar enough that we might
expect recent transmission
person-to-person transmission so here we
set out look there's a bunch of cases
that have the same fingerprint all these
blue cases might potentially be related
but in order to draw the connections
between those cases we need to
contact investigation we need to do
field epidemiology where we go out and
we talk to these patients and we try and
understand who they have social contacts
with where they live where they work who
do they see in those places etc etc so
this is work decently enough for the
past decade or so but there are some
challenges fingerprinting DNA
fingerprinting only tells you that there
is a cluster of potential cases and an
often over estimates clustering as
you'll see in a little bit so it just
tells you that cases are related
potentially related to each other it
doesn't give you any sort of
directionality if you want that
directionality you have to go in and do
your contact investigation do that field
epidemiological work and that can be
challenging sometimes for a lot of
reasons you know not the least of which
is that public health is fairly resource
limited we don't often have people that
we can send out to investigate every
single outbreak all the time and
depending on the fingerprinting method
that you use you might end up with
slightly different results so most
laboratories now are using 24 locus
mirrors vntr analysis but before that we
used to use 12 loci and I can tell you
that when we switch from 12 22 24 loci
on the number of outbreaks that we
thought we had on our hand decreased
because we had a higher resolution
technique so as I said earlier when I
was recapping what we were doing with
tuberculosis in British Columbia we did
that big retrospective analysis looking
at all the culture positive TB cases
going back to 2005 if we look at that
complete decade of TB and their mirror
vntr genotypes their DNA fingerprints
this is the diagram that we get each of
these circles represents a different
unique genotype and the bigger the
circle the more people we observed that
genotype in their colored according to
birthplace genomically we know that TB
kind of falls into a couple different
lineages we describe these as things
like the euro-american lineage or the
east asian lineage you can see that most
of the TB in BC is your American TB
certainly most of the large clusters
those big nodes occur with euro-american
lineages the genotypes in the other
lineages tend to be Singleton's we only
see them once so this type of
information can be very helpful to tell
us how much potential transmission is
there and if you go just on genotyping
data alone you would estimate that in
British Columbia 42% of our isolates are
clustered so potentially 42 percent of
cases are the result of transmission
happening in BC but there's a problem
with that and there's it's that
resolution problem that I mentioned a
couple of slides ago mirrors Engr is
only locating best-case-scenario at 24
variable number tandem repeat locations
scattered around the MTB genome it's not
looking at all of the available
information so when you're doing
genotyping I like to explain it as it's
like you're looking at a picture but you
pick a 99% of the pixels of the
information away you get a rough idea
for what the image might be but it's
only when you look at a hundred percent
of the pixels that the image actually
snaps into much clearer focus so this
kind of goddess thinking about genome
sequencing as a tool to get 100% of the
pixels in focus
mirror vntr is just looking at a
fraction of the genome whole genome
sequencing looks at the whole genome so
that is what gave rise to back when we
were doing that original 40 TB genomes
project a decade ago
this emerging field of genomic
epidemiology which is simply reading the
entire genome of all of the isolates
from a particular outbreak to try to
look for clues about who transmitted to
whom and the simplest way of explaining
it is with the analogy of the children's
game of telephone where you've got kids
in a line somebody whispers a sentence
to the first kid in line who then
whispers it to the next kid to the next
kid to the next kid and by the time the
sentence reaches the end of the line it
has changed its mutated as it spreads
from kid to kid to kid the same sort of
thing is happening to the Mycobacterium
tuberculosis genome as it's transmitted
from person to person in an outbreak so
what we're doing with genomic
epidemiology is really the equivalent of
doing this kids game you know whispering
a sentence and then telling the kids
just go shuffle yourselves around the
room randomly go to any old spot in the
room then you go around to each kid in
turn and you say okay what did you hear
what sentence did you hear what did you
hear and from what they tell you you try
to figure out the order that they were
sitting in so if the word cat changed to
the word back in some of the sentences
you'll be able to determine that the
kids that all heard cat or sitting in
one part of the line together the kids
that hurt that or sitting in another
part of the line together and right away
you've managed to divide your outbreak
of children into two separate groups the
groups that heard cats the group that
heard that so really what we're doing
with genomic epidemiology is just that
but rich on a much larger scale we are
instead of asking the kids what sentence
did you hear we're sequencing the MTB
genome from a particular patient and the
mutations in that genome are just like
the mutations in our sentence and we
look for shared patterns of mutations
across particular individuals to figure
out within one large outbreak what are
the smaller sub clusters that might help
us to refine transmission further so if
we go back to that mirror vntr
fingerprinting diagram and we sequence
all of the isolates that share a mirrors
entr genotype with at least one of their
isolate we get a phylogenetic tree that
looks like this here the red bars
indicate samples that were taken from
people born in Canada gray bars are
samples MTB genomes from people born
outside Canada and the black dots
indicate those isolates in our data set
that happened to be multi drug-resistant
if you use this data to give you a much
more accurate estimation of the true
rate of transmission or clustering of TB
and BC your estimate of clustered cases
drops from 42 percent with neuro vntr
genotyping to only 24 percent with whole
genome sequencing
in other words one in every four cases
of TB BC is transmitted person-to-person
is potentially preventable so just to
give you an idea of what that data looks
like this is the data from one
particular outbreak each row in this
multiple sequence alignment corresponds
to a Mycobacterium tuberculosis genome
from a different patient and the MTB
genome in total is about 4.4 million
letter long but over the course of a
multi multi multi year outbreak which is
what you're seeing here there's only a
handful of positions you know maybe 15
or 20 where mutations actually happen so
we can ignore the rest of the genome the
genome that's unchanged across all of
our outbreak isolates and we can focus
our attention just on those interesting
positions where there's variation and
that's what you see here and visually
right away with this little coloring
scheme you can Intuit that there are
particular groups of patients who have
identical or near identical isolates to
each other but are just different enough
from some of the other patients that you
can say okay well maybe these people
didn't directly transmitted to each
other so to walk you through this
particular example these isolates at the
top of this multiple sequence alignment
were ones that were diagnosed around
2001 to 2004 we have done some
historical sequencing back further than
2005 and we see lots of diversity here
TB mutates at a rate of approximately
half a mutation per year so for seeing
mutations that say you know 10 different
positions that suggests about streams
been circulating for at least 20 years
it's been going around for a while if we
look at this little group down here all
of these were cases that were diagnosed
in one particular part of British
Columbia and you can see they're almost
virtually identical there's just this
one interesting position where an a and
some isolates turns into a see in other
isolates so we can take that group of
individuals and suddenly divide them
into two and saying well you know if you
have the C mutation odds are you
received your infection from somebody
else with the C mutation and gave it to
somebody that had a C mutation
these were some interesting isolates -
they were separated by thousands of
kilometers in four years apart but there
are only two mutations different but it
turned out when we dug into that story a
little bit further they actually
happened to be in the same place at the
same time many years before and would
have received their infection at the
same time from the same source so this
is the type of data the what it actually
looks like the type of analysis that we
do on this I won't go into great detail
on because it's pretty mathematical and
now it's pretty early in the morning
when you're watching this presentation
but we've done a lot of work over the
years on combining evolutionary and
statistical models for identifying who
transmitted to whom just from that
genomic information alone so there's a
lot of math that goes into it but we can
tell not only just who transmitted to
WHO but likely when that transmission
occurred as well and we did this with a
second large outbreak that we
investigated remember that TB has that
latent phase so you might be infected
and take many years to progress to
active disease or you might develop
active disease right away so with genome
sequencing we're able to answer
questions like okay for every case in
the outbreaks and this was a no break
that got up to nearly 50 cases when did
that individual receive their infection
when was the actual outbreak happening
this is really useful in an interesting
information for Public Health it helped
tell us when transmissions stopped and
that in turn allows us to declare
outbreaks of TB over so this is some
work that we've been continuing on with
for the last few years this is the most
recent paper that came out from that
last year in molecular biology and
evolution again just figuring out
automated ways of reconstructing
transmission events just from genomic
alone so a really powerful tool for
understanding TB epidemiology even if
you can't necessarily get out there in
the community and ask so I'll finish
with one very quick story of paper that
we published earlier this year in ji D
looking at pediatric TB cases TB in
children in BC so we had
over that study retrospective study
period there were nearly 100 cases of
pediatric TB and we had sequence of all
material for 1/2 of those we also had
lots of really interesting information
like where was that child born where
were their parents born if they were
born outside of Canada or their parents
were born outside of Canada when did
they immigrate to the country that they
have a travel history of going back to
say their parents birth country for
extended vacation and we have this large
data set of all these genotypes and all
these genome sequencing results so what
we found when we use genomics to answer
the question where did children in
British Columbia get their TB from as we
found it was very dependent on how old
that child was and where they and their
parents were born so in the subsequent
slides the color scheme here is going to
be a kind of burgundy to represent
children that were born in Canada to
parents who were also born in Canada the
pink bar is lighter pink are children
that were born in Canada whose parents
were born outside Canada and blue are
children that were not born in Canada
they were born overseas so in the age
distribution of cases you can see that
Canadian born cases tend to be younger
foreign-born cases of active TB tend to
be teenagers and where contact
investigation and field epidemiology had
suggested a potential source of a
child's TB whole genome sequencing
confirmed that so in our Canadian born
children with Canadian born parents it
was often visitors to the home community
members or sometimes adult household
contacts for almost all of our children
that were Canadian born with
foreign-born parents it was an adult
household contact often a parent that
genomics indicated was the source and we
did have one child that was born
overseas who was transmitted to NBC from
an adult household contact so in total
of the 49 pediatric cases that we
negated whole genome sequencing
suggested that 15 of those were the
result of transmission in BC and the
rest of those are kind of buried
we had canadian-born children whose
parents were born overseas and those
kids traveled back to those countries so
they probably acquired their TV abroad
we believe that almost all of the
foreign-born children acquired the TB
before they emigrated to Canada now
there are a couple of mysteries too so
genomics can't solve everything we can
only sequence the isolates that we have
access to which in our case were the
ones from BC but it can tell us some
really interesting things and so it to
us that suggested that one of the things
that we do when we diagnose a pediatric
cases TB something called reverse
contact investigation we don't
necessarily need to do that if we see an
older child who was born overseas
because the genome sequencing work tells
us that they probably didn't get their
infection in BC it was probably the
result of acquisition prior to
immigration or as a result of travel so
this is a really small but interesting
example of how genome sequencing can
really change how we do our TB care so
what are we doing next we're still
looking at that retrospective data set
as well as analyzing all of our new data
we've got a very cool project where
we're looking at our transmission
networks we've divided people into
people that transmit and people that
don't transmit and we're combining that
with some linked administrative data we
have to answer some questions like are
there particular clinical or
epidemiological characteristics that
mean that somebody's more likely to
transmit TB than somebody else and are
there features of a small TB outbreak
that would allow us to predict whether
that outbreak is going to grow and
become a particular problem later on so
this is some work that we're doing with
machine learning and predictive
analytics so to sum up TV is a really
interesting organism to work in it's got
a really straightforward genome to
analyze with whole genome sequencing but
we can act and answer a lot of really
important
questions around diagnosis around
treatment around transmission and when
we use that information that we're
deriving from whole genome sequence is
the basis for changing how we do TB
practice to be policy in British
Columbia we really think we can progress
towards elimination so lots of people
contributed to this work including folks
at the BC Center for Disease Control in
the BC Public Health lab collaborators
up in Yukon Territory collaborators at
Oxford University and public health
England and around the world I've seen a
tremendously exciting project to work on
and we're really excited to see where
our TB genome sequencing analysis takes
us next thank you all so much for
joining in and I'm happy to take your
questions please do send them on to me
thanks again
thank you dr. Gardy for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
Q&A portion of the webinar and we'll
address some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do - so now just click on the
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button our speaker will follow up with
your questions via email
so let's get started our first question
dr. Garvey is what role in genomics play
in higher TB incidence settings yeah
that's an excellent question so the work
that I presented here largely in these
low incidence settings places like BC
and we have very different needs and
very different end goals than a higher
incidence setting so while I think the
priority for high incidence countries
really does need to be on simple rapid
case identification and getting people
on antibiotic therapy right away just
using simple laboratory techniques you
don't need a whole genome sequencing for
that what I think it's going to do is a
couple things I think first of all as we
start to sequence more and more TB in
low incidence settings that's going to
tell us a lot of stuff about the TB
genome that we can use to develop better
rapid non-genomic point-of-care testing
for higher burden settings so we're just
going to be generating a lot of
knowledge that's going to help us do
better Diagnostics for lower and
middle-income countries I think there's
also some interesting things that
genomics can do we know that in certain
high burden countries reporting of TB
cases isn't always perfect the actual
number of TB cases usually far exceeds
the number that are reported to the
government and with some of the
population genomic analyses where we're
using that evolutionary biology and the
math modeling we can actually look at TB
genome sampled from a population and
estimate the true population size you
know we will only sequenced a thousand
TB genomes but based on the diversity we
see how large is the true population
that's out there so I think that can be
quite informative in terms of saying
okay is this country really on target
with their reporting or is there a lot
of undiscovered TB out there that maybe
we need to come up with better
programmatic ways of identifying so
while I don't think whole genome
sequencing is going to become routinely
used in high burden settings any time
soon I think there's a lot that we can
learn from its deployment elsewhere that
can feedback and result in better policy
and practice in
those settings
thank you dr. Gardie and this next
question is actually two parts what
about mixed infections or within hosts
genetic variations how does that affect
your results yeah that's a great
question
so because TB has this latency period
because of the chronic infection and
hangs out in people's lungs for a while
you might expect that the TB bacterium
within an individual the population of
TB bacteria might have a little bit of
variation in there so we've been working
on some methods to account for the fact
that you know what if what if one person
harbors you know two types of TB one
where it's got a mutation at a
particular position and maybe another
where that mutation doesn't exist tell
you then infer who they might have
transmitted to because some people are
going to receive one variant some people
are going to receive the other variant
so we've been working to solve that with
a bunch of different mathematical models
the other question the other parts that
mixed infection we know from genotyping
studies that in high incidence settings
as many as one in five people can be
infected with two different strains of
TB at the same time this doesn't really
happen in lower incidence settings like
British Columbia but it is a problem in
higher burden settings unfortunately
when we do deep whole genome sequencing
we can actually bioinformatics
separate out those two strings we can
identify mixed infections and we can
analyze each one of those populations
separately it's a very very new area of
research there's just been a few papers
on it this year but yeah the sequencing
technology allows us to and if
deconvolute those
thank you dr. Guardian we have one more
question will genomics completely
replace the current protocols in the TV
laboratory yeah
so I think in places like public health
England you've had almost a
near-complete switchover
the only thing that's really still
happening is phenotypic drug sensitivity
testing and with some results that was
part of this large international
consortium have coming out soon I think
in certain settings where the prevalence
of drug-resistant TB is extremely low I
think within two to five years you might
see whole genome sequencing completely
replacing all of the traditional
laboratory steps you would only do
things like phenotypic drug sensitivity
testing if the drug the predicted
resistance of your isolate suggests a
certain treatment regimen but then your
patient isn't responding there's some
sort of empirical evidence that the
treatment isn't working then you might
go in and do phenotypic DST but I think
at certain settings we are looking at a
future where whole genome sequencing
could be it as I said earlier certainly
not in higher burden settings lower
middle-income countries but in certain
state and regional and national
reference laboratories I think it's a
very very real possibility
thank you and dr. Cardy would you like
to provide our viewers with some closing
remarks before we go yeah absolutely
this is one one little slice of a
fascinating world of Public Health
genomics I think TB is one of the areas
where because the TB genome is
relatively straightforward and because
it's such a critically important
pathogen in terms of global Public
Health it's certainly being one of the
ones that has been most studied with the
genomic approach and we've made a lot of
really interesting theoretical and
practical ground work here but the stuff
that we've done in TB is totally
extensible to other pathogens and as
we're starting to you know as a Public
Health and microbiology community really
trying to get a handle on what it seems
like sort of increasing numbers of
epidemics you know we've got
hospital-acquired outbreaks and
superbugs left right and center
foodborne illness outbreaks happening
regularly emerging infectious diseases
in the viral space more and more Ebola
outbreaks zika virus all of these sorts
of techniques are applicable across that
array of pathogens so it's a really
exciting time to be somebody who's able
to combine bacteriology virology with
genomics with computational biology and
with epidemiology and I think it's going
to be one of the most interesting and
most productive areas of biomedical
research in the coming year so is it
it's a great place to work you'll never
be without a job thank you so much dr.
Garvey for your presentation and your
important research we also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2018 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share this announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now and
thanks for joining us hope to see you
again soon bye bye